Hello, this is Sonny calling from a very rainy Houston,
Texas radio lab is supported by dash digital cash dash allows you to send any
amount of money using a highly secure peer to peer network,
skip the bank entirely and control your money your way.
Dash his digital cash. For more information,
visit dash.org forward slash radio lab.
You're listening to radio lab from New York public radio, public radio,
W Y C o n n p.
R.
[inaudible].
This is Radiolab on Jab and Rod. Today we're in a Dr Frankston sorta mood,
so we figure we're better to start dusk tests at the museum.
American Museum of Natural History where they have on it kind of frankensteining
exit. Okay. I'm Laurel Candle.
I curate the American Museum of Natural History as exhibit mythic creatures
where we lit and when you look more closely you realize that they're all mashups
from the natural world. For example,
she takes us over to one corner points at a class case we're inside.
What you're seeing is this creepy little hybrid skeleton thing.
Look at this space and see how it really is a composite.
Half of it is a monkey, the upper half monkey skull,
and the lower half is a fish tail, like some kind of trout with some scales,
places full of stuff like this. A lion with an eagle head.
Humans with snake tails. Just about anything you can imagine. Very operatic. Oh,
and I forgot to mention the most important part.
Okay.
Tons and tons of kids completely in awe. Oh my God. Uniform.
Oh, why are we standing under here?
The Pegasus? Can you describe what we're seeing here? It's a horse.
The body's like a horse. It has these really big wings, wings like birds,
like an eagle. Maybe. Somehow his parents were a horse and a bird in there.
Their jeans for him together too, might make the Pegasus.
What I see, like what I see,
it just looks like exciting that it just looks really cool.
And when you ask these kids, is there a producer? Literally Miller did.
Why is it cool? Like why is it fun to see two animals mashed together?
Will they just look at you like you're dumb? So ours will ring.
Birds have wings. Yes. Um, birds.
They're not mythical.
They're like the regular every day you see them,
every time you just see a pigeon you let go, whatever. Maybe it's that simple.
Yeah. Any case, the kids,
their sick of us and our dumb questions ran off to this kiosk at the museum.
It's set up around the corner over right here where they could actually build
their own creatures. Okay. Now can you describe your guy here?
He has seven heads and yes,
tail with fire on it for a leg and he has a long body and the thing is kind of
like
you can't help but wonder if these same kids in about 30 or 40 years might
actually be able to do this for real.
When that grown up,
those kids will be at home in the new world of biotechnology.
They won't be ready to put their skills to use.
That will be do it yourself kits to breed new varieties of pigeons and parrots
and lizards and snakes and buy like a snake and then like a bird.
Oh can I do it? Cause I never got to do that.
Genetic engineering once it gets into the hands of housewives and children will
give us an explosion of diversity of new living creatures.
That is physicists, Freeman Dyson. We'll hear more from him later now,
whether it's true or not, what he's saying,
it does seem to be the case that we are at this pivotal point now where the
stuff that we used to only have imagine might actually turn into reality,
which is why maybe you get an exhibit of fantasy creatures at the Museum of
natural history. This is
abrasion of the human imagination. Human, yes.
Living creatures. That is physicists, Freeman Dyson.
We'll hear more from him later now, whether it's true or not, what he's saying,
it does seem to be the case that we are at this pivotal point now where the
stuff that we used to only have imagine might actually turn into reality,
which is why maybe you get an exhibit of fantasy creatures at the Museum of
natural history. This is syllabus
abrasion of the human imagination, human ingenuity, human art.
[inaudible] I know what it been like to be gone.
[inaudible]
that word you, you mentioned, um, natural. Yeah. That one natural.
What does it mean exactly? Let's just take, usually means what it means,
what's familiar, but we know what we know. Let's say,
let's just muck that up a bit because it turns out when you look in nature,
you will find things that are frankly very strange and not familiar. Like,
well, let me tell you a story.
It's an amazing story about a woman heard about it from a reporter,
Soren Wheeler. Hi Soren. Right. Hey, it's a Soren. Tell me about Karen. Well,
Karen is a mother of three,
a middle aged woman living outside of Boston and the suburbs of Boston. And uh,
she lives there with her husband, Pete. The kids are out of the house now.
Tell me what you were thinking when you walked up to her door. Well, I,
I was nervous. I was kind of strangely nervous about meeting her.
Hi Karen. Hi. But I got there and she was friendly as can be,
bring in a couple cups of tea. She made me tea,
we sat in the living room and talk and uh, she was just normal,
which it's
kind of weird given the story that she was about to tell me.
So let's start at the very beginning. Oh,
well in 1995,
I was told that I needed a kidney transplant immediately.
What's that like? Like what are you going through? It was frightening.
The doctors told Karen they needed to act fast.
They asked me who in my family might be willing to donate a kidney.
The two older boys, that's Matt and Jess and Karen's husband Pete,
you all went in to get what should have been a pretty routine DNA test. Yep.
They had the blood work done and they waited.
A couple of weeks later I got a phone call from the hospital and they said,
Mrs Keegan, um,
this is a very unusual situation that we're going to explain to you.
Uh, it's something that we've never seen before.
But uh,
when the DNA testing was done on your sons,
we found that they didn't match your DNA.
Is that how they said it? They said they match the father,
but they're not a match for you. What does that mean? They didn't match her DNA.
She's not their mother. Oh, ready?
Much hearing this was crazy. Yeah. She told them, well, I was there.
This could not possibly be these kids. I felt the pain. You know,
you better do the test again because you're obviously wrong.
And so they did do the test again. Same result. The Reid was correct.
There was not a laboratory error. This is one of her doctors. When you, we,
we felt particularly after the second time that it was real.
And then they said,
now we have had situations where the husband's DNA didn't match,
but we've never had a mother whose DNA didn't match their children.
So wait, if the DNA is saying she's not the mom,
then what would explain that first thought was that there was some kind of mix
up,
some sweatshirt babies or something like a baby switch right after birth kind of
thing. Yeah. But the problem with that is that the dad is the dad.
Those are the father's, right.
So you have to figure it like how could they have gotten the wrong kid,
but the right dad says, then what if, if that's the case,
here's the thing at this, at this point, further involved with this.
People are thinking maybe Karen's done something kind of fishing.
There must be something that you're not being told.
Like maybe she implanted her womb with another woman's baby and then she just
kind of lied about it. Yeah. That she lied about it. They said, well,
could you tell us what hospital you had these children in? How exactly, how,
what, what would,
I'm still confused as being accused of being some kind of monster.
Maybe wish they had children or stolen a child or something.
Had to be, because obviously DNA is never it wrong. It's never wrong.
Wow.
So how does she talk to her family about this and what are those conversations
like?
I do remember some very sort of sad moments with my sons.
Yeah. You know, I told them,
I don't think they maybe even completely realized what I was saying when Karen's
doctor couldn't get this out of her head. Something wasn't adding up.
Didn't make sense.
So she thought about the fact that they'd done all of the tests on Karen's
blood, only in our blood cells.
So Lynn started thinking maybe the next step they ought to look at some other
parts. And to do that we would need to test other tissues,
scraped the inside of your mouth and get a little saliva and maybe a hair or to
thyroid ladder and a skin biopsy with you're getting all sorts of parts.
You're getting along all parts and all kinds of parts from me.
That's when things started to get strange.
When we got the results of the tissue studies, we identified two,
two to two sets of DNA to people to to what?
Another person in Karen,
she had another person inside her. Well sort of.
She did have a separate set of DNA.
So it was like she had another person with its own genetic identity in her body.
Oh,
and the thing is that that other person that was the mother of the boys,
well how did we get there? That, I mean that's what the doctors were wondering.
So they all sit down,
put their heads together and try to figure it out and then it hit them.
You were a twin, you are a twin. She,
I mean she had a twin. No, she's both twins.
Here's what happened in Karen's mother's womb.
Originally there were two eggs, two fertilized eggs,
twin girls side by side developing in their own separate sacks.
Then after a couple of days, something strange happens.
Somehow the two embryos bumped into each other
and they fused into one unit and that one became Karen.
Like a mixture of the two of them. Well, no, they,
they didn't blend according to Lynn.
What happened is they kind of claimed different parts of,
they still had their own, I want to say boundaries.
One twin claimed her blood and the other twin claimed her thyroid and her
bladder and took Karen is a plural. Okay.
[inaudible]
hey is this, has this, has this happened before? Well,
supposedly it's pretty rare, but it does happen. In fact, there's,
there's a scientific word for this condition.
Karen first heard that word from her doctor, Margot Cresco.
Margo [inaudible] came to my,
explained that I was a Chi Kemira a term which I had never heard of.
Did she? Did she come and say you're Kymera did? Yeah.
Yes.
Now that was interesting because I called my son the English major and said,
Matt, I've found out I was a Chi Mirah, and he said, oh, well,
you know what a Chi Mira is, don't you? And I said, no. And he said,
well,
in the ancient Greek myths, I,
Thai Mira is an animal that has like a lion,
has a donkey's cool a goat, Kale, you know,
it's a mixture. A Greek missed the Camaro was a monster,
but the heroes opposed to slay.
That didn't make me feel very good.
Then Karen learned more about what Kymera meant medically and what could've
happened to her.
If the eggs hadn't fused. Within four days,
I would have become a Siamese twin.
When you hear that,
you immediately have a more concrete vision of two selves.
It brought home the reality that I really was a twin.
She is a twin. One doctor said, do you think you have two souls?
I think of myself as the onion,
but there is almost a sort of subtle sadness to think that I would have had a
sister. Yeah.
And so there is sort of a shadow feeling of loss.
There could have been more
thanks to reporter sewer and wheeler for that.
Let's make things a little more disturbing now because human beings,
scientists are now capable of creating kindnesses purposefully.
Can we talk to Lee silver who was a scientist at Princeton elite. Okay. Lee,
you have to say something.
Okay. You know my left ear is receiving more than my right. Is there a,
when he told us about an intentional Kymera,
a creature created by a Danish embryologist named steam will ITSM,
he took a goat embryo and a sheep embryo and he pushed them together in his
petri dish.
But that mixture of embryo back into a female,
I don't remember which species.
And then what was born was an animal that was part goat, part sheep,
and he called that a jeep.
Was it visibly kind of Godi and kind of sheepy? Well it was actually, yes,
it was very visible. And what happened because of the way development occurs,
parts of its body looks, sheep like and parts of its body look goat.
Like which parts? Well,
and he did this multiple times and so he actually got multiple gifts and
sometimes the animal would have a goat head,
but then parts of its body would be sheep, like with wool.
Other Times would have a sheet pan. How confusing it would be at the wipe dance.
You would know like who was supposed of dance with home could,
could keeps relate with one another in that way.
I don't remember the father.
You may look for that little beard and everything in the hooves
mean just to give you a visual.
We've got a picture here of three jeeps hanging out near a tree.
Do you want to describe it? Well, the Geek,
one of them looks like a naked animal wearing the coat of shaggy hair does.
It's got this streak of sheep wool running on its back,
but the rest of it looks kind of Godi. Which deal do you find a cute?
I kind of do find it cute. Well, but now let's uncurated a bit.
Suppose instead of talking about mixing sheep with goats, okay,
since you're not a sheep or a goat, let's make it more personal.
Um,
people are most worried about combining human embryonic cells and monkey or
chimp embryonic cells.
And so the idea is if you took a chimp embryo in a human embryo and you push
them together based on the Geek results,
based on lots of other data that scientists have accumulated,
it's very likely that you'd have an organism born that was part chimp,
part human will there once was a creature like that.
Because if you believe in evolution,
you believe that chimps eventually became humans.
So somewhere in history there is someone who is 10% chimp and 90% [inaudible].
And that common ancestor evolved continuously and slowly from a chimp like,
um, individual to human. And in every point along the 100,000 generations,
the children didn't look very different from their parents.
The, here's the, here's the very sad Hollywood movie.
I go and I go and I create a creature,
a deep like, you know, amalgamation,
which is 50% chimpanzee ape.
And 50% human homosapians and he's the only one that's like creating a tragedy.
It seems like because you'd be creating someone who is isolated in his
physiology.
Yes. I mean this could breed with him or maybe they could, but, well,
I'm going to this cost. You're taping this opening something.
I'm opening something. This is actually a play here. Look,
look at this. It's going to be performed next week. Sweet. Sweet Motherhood,
isn't it? That's it.
So this is a play at the Guthrie Theater in Minneapolis.
Shelly McGahn wants a baby, a human chimpanzee baby.
Oh.
Shelly's been spending too much time partying to build up a respectable grade
point average. So she proposes the following senior thesis,
fertilize one of her eggs with the sperm from a chimpanzee in her womb.
It's an interesting term paper.
So professor Harry Stein must do everything he can to stop her.
The play is inspired by a true event.
Really? This is your play. Yes.
Jeremy character is the main playwright and I had collaborated with him.
What is the true of, I want to, this is base. The true event is that a,
about 10, 12 years ago now,
I was talking to my usual flippant way to a bunch of students and a sequence
information had just come out showing that chimps and humans were almost 90% the
same at the DNA level. And so I just threw out the idea, well,
based on what we know about goats and sheep and everything else,
you probably could have a hybrid developed between a chimpanzee and human being.
It was a thought experiment. What would it be? How would it developed?
Which of its characteristics would be human, which would be chimpanzee?
The next day a student,
a junior came to my office and said she wanted to do the experiment inside her
own womb. Ah, and uh, so then yes, uh,
in real life, what did you do?
He hit her on the head with a baseball bat or why? No, I had a long,
I was flabbergasted.
She was absolutely serious because it's actually true. She, she was,
this student partied a lot and she needed,
and the senior thesis at Princeton counts enormous amount in towards your final
GPA. So, uh, she wanted to do this unique experiment,
hoping she'd get an a plus in her senior thesis. She was very naive obviously.
That was the last time I saw this little chimpanzee up for adoption as soon as
it was born. Well, no, no where she, she, I asked her,
what would you do with this individual? I said, well, if it's a human being,
you have to raise it like a human being and as rights, like human being.
If it's a chimpanzee, you put her in a zoo or you use it,
use it for experiments and what's it going to be?
And her answer to that question was she would have bought right before,
um, it came time to go into labor sheet, a board.
And so the whole idea of the senior thesis was to study the development of this
hybrid inside of her womb. She really wanted to do this for real,
not just on paper for a project, but actually she herself. Yes.
Now there are many, many, many,
many problems to do, meaning liberal arts education,
liberal here. And we talked for an hour. Um, I dissuaded her.
I never saw her again,
except in a way in his play, the, when he coat road.
This is the play about the teacher at the fancy university happens just to be
teaching theology class.
The human ovary within the masters body happens to have this notion about what
would it be like if chimps and humans had babies together. Actually in a number,
I am more similar to a MailChimp than I am to my sister,
happens to have in the play a student who comes up after class and says,
combine one of my eggs with chimpanzees want you to donate except by the way in
the play
she actually goes through with it.
Hi Craig, this.
But you know, he,
he wrote the play to keep a conversation going that wouldn't get out of his
hand. And the question is what is a human being? Um,
if you look at a developmentally,
evolutionarily through these hybrids and tiny areas,
where's the boundary between human being and non human being?
And at the end of my, uh, quest,
I personally concluded that there is no boundary. No, no, no, no.
It's fuzzy. So in other words, if you look at,
the analogy I like to give is look at the color spectrum between green and blue.
When you go from green to blue along the color spectrum,
it's a continuous gradual change from one to the other.
There's no point in which you say, here's the boundary between green and blue,
and if you take that analogy, which I did, two human beings,
you say during development or in evolution in the,
in terms of a Kemira, there's no boundary,
but the social effect of having staked out that position is that you aren't
going to defend our species against all kinds of amendments.
There is a consequence to this kind of thinking, right? I mean,
you can't do it cold porter, anything goes, can you know? No,
I don't believe you can do anything goes. My purpose is to say,
not that anything goes,
but that in theory all these outrageous things could happen and actually are
happening. Here's an example.
Since 1980 scientists have been taking human genes,
genetic information, putting it into mice.
I mean this is sort of a routine procedure and for people who do mouse molecular
genetics,
and in fact the really exciting thing that people are doing now is they're
making cows that are engineered to produce human blood.
And the idea is that you want to change all the genes in the cow that normally
produced the proteins in cow blood.
You want to make them all human so you'd have a cow making human blood.
I don't think most people would mind that.
And then you could use it for blood transfusions. Wow.
Could you make a cow with human blood and a human kidney so that you could use
that too? Well, actually a met, they've uh,
Israeli scientists have already created a mouse that has a tiny little
functioning human kidney get out. Yeah,
I can show you the picture. Yeah. So I mean,
and you know when there are other people who are working with sheep and trying
to make human livers and side sheep and,
and the whole ideas is regenerative medicine.
You sacrifice the animals to get a new kidney for you. Now.
I actually think that as long as you don't play with the external features,
I think society will accept it. I mean, you know,
people eat pigs and if you can eat a pig,
why not grow a pig to have a human liver or kidney or heart?
As long as it still looks like a pig. He said, that's right.
As long as it still looks like a pig and it still behaves like a pig. You know,
if you put a human arm onto a pig, I don't think people would like that.
But you acknowledged that the distinctions you're drawing are emotional
distinctions and not rational. Absolutely. There are emotional,
and I'm saying that sometimes emotional distinctions matter. I mean,
I have no solutions. I mean, I don't know where to draw lines.
Society has the draw lines.